in a similar fashion to the initial
batch of mandalorian episodes season 2
appears equally as plentiful in the
easter egg department here are the
secrets lurking in the backgrounds that
you probably missed
right off the bat the season premiere
kicks off in jaron's journey to find the
remaining mandalorians hidden across the
galaxy he hopes that they can help him
relocate the child aka baby yoda to
wherever he came from
and by extension lead him to his family
as well however this won't be a
one-and-done task as a mandalorian sex
are notoriously difficult to locate
meaning the titular bounty hunter has to
ask around to locate his people
the first stop for mando is to meet up
with an absin a call back to a cantina
alien from 1977's a new hope
named gore koresh on a cd unnamed planet
there the two converse drawing some type
of combat sport involving two gamorians
squaring off with vibro axes inside
something resembling a boxing ring
these pig-faced aliens made their star
wars debut in 1983's return of the jedi
posing as guards for the gangster jabba
the hutt
with the underworld kingpin long gone
from the time of the mandalorian
it appears his former palace rogues are
doing their best to make ends meet
along them were a handful of week way
which just so happens to be the same
race as mopel goes rather than bartender
who just so happens to be played by w.l
brown who played the bartender dan
doherty
on hbo's deadwood opposite timothy
oliphant who happens to play marshall
kobfanth in this episode of the
mandalorian
but we're getting ahead of ourselves
after concluding his lesson cordial
meeting with koresh
mando and his foundling make their way
to tatooine to look for the supposed
mandalorian
wandering the planet's sandy dunes of
course they can't get a good look around
the planet from the razor crest
so they enlist the hangar of peli motto
who first appeared in the mandalorian's
inaugural season
alongside her crew of pedroids but
they're not the only droids running amok
as a familiar face pops up to help mando
navigate tatooine's perilous terrain
motto sought the map of tatooine inside
an r5 astromech unit
that fans of a new hope likely
recognized immediately in a new hope
luke skywalker goes after purchase from
the jawas a new droid for the family
moisture farm and the red and white
r5d4 was his first choice sadly the
little guy didn't get to go off and have
galaxy-wide adventures with the future
jedi thanks to a bad motivator
so that spark went to the fan favorite
r2d2
it's good to see that motto could fix
him up even if he's a bit sluggish for
her liking
now take your time seriously you just
can't get good help anymore
the vast majority of season 2's first
episode takes place on tatooine which is
one of the most important locations in
the star wars universe
koresha's lead sends mando to the off
the grid town of mos pelgo
but bookworms would recognize it by
another name freetown
chuck wendig's 2015 novel aftermath
introduced a village
describing it as a dirty sparsely
populated settlement
that wasn't for the faint of hut the
mandalorian season 2 premiere however
marks the first appearance of the
rundown community in any visual medium
additionally during a discussion with
the mandalorian about mos pelgo
peli motto name drops some other
recognizable tatooine locales
first and foremost she mentions moses
eisley a wretched hive of scum and
villainy the house chao mum's catina and
played a pivotal role in both the new
hope and the mandalorian season one
mose esper the home of watto's junkyard
and the birthplace of anakin skywalker
received a not too
thus rounding out tatooine's few major
settlements also on tatooine those
adorable womb rats finally getting the
close-up they deserve but it's not
impossible i used to bull's-eye womp
rats in my t-16 back home they're not
much bigger than two meters
upon arriving at the largely and
remarkable moes pelgo
mando enters the local cantina to speak
with anyone who can provide him with
information
on the town's supposed mandalorian
resident fernando the result was pretty
disappointing
he didn't find one of his people but
rather kobvanth who was simply wearing
the armor with no ties to the creed
it doesn't take a deep knowledge of star
wars to recognize the gear as boba fett
although if you only watch the movies
and tv shows you'll have to do some
digging to learn about cobb vance
vanth made his debut in the star wars
universe in the aforementioned aftermath
novel
the book details his journey pretty
vaguely running over the broad strokes
of him receiving the armor from the
jawas
and subsequently saving freetown from
marauders and tuscan raiders
thus earning the moniker the marshall
which is why the season 2 premiere bears
that name
the mandalorian certainly picks up the
slack putting van front and center with
a series of flashbacks
to supply a bit more detail than the
book could pull off
committed as ever to his beliefs mando
refuses to allow vans to keep the
mandalorian armor since it technically
doesn't belong to him
since both of them are rational men they
come to an agreement that will service
both parties
mando can have every last piece of armor
so long as he helps van to take down
once and for all the carnivorous beast
known as the crate dragon
that's ravaged most pell go for years
they might not realize what they're
dealing with but long time star wars
fans instantly recognized the danger the
two were in
crate dragons are as old as star wars
itself first appearing in the background
of a new hope
after c-3po and r2d2 crashed land in the
middle of the dune sea
a crate dragon skeleton sits in the sand
way off in the distance
obi-wan kenobi later even mimics what
many fans assumed to be a great dragon's
howl to scare away some tuscan raiders
despite holding a constant menacing
presence across all forms of star wars
media crate dragons live ones anyway
are an incredibly rare sight throughout
the canon most of the time the story
relegates them to a fleeting mention
or a set piece used to fill in space
even though they're massive beasts with
highly valuable pearls in their bellies
in some non-canonical star wars media
it's said these pearls can even be used
to craft the lightsabers
after making their agreement cop vanta
the mandalorian made their way across
the dune sea
in pursuit of the crate dragon such a
long stretch of sand and scorching heat
is impossible to trek on foot so the two
found alternative transportation
to reach their destination mando rides
off on the same speeder bike he borrowed
from pelimoto
but vanth pulls up in something quite
out of the ordinary his makeshift
vehicle sported two large flaps on the
front
covering a turbine set below them with a
seating area attached to the rear this
hodgepodge of components calls back to
the phantom menace's pod racers
sporting a similar look to young
anakin's model there's no way to confirm
if it came from his specifically
but the pieces undeniably came from
someone's pod racer which is a neat nod
to the prequels
with the great dragon defeated cop van
keeps his word in return to mandalorian
armor set to dinjarin
the episode concludes with the two
parting ways as allies and the best card
clad bounty hunter rides off into the
sunset with the child at his side
per usual the episode's story looked
complete there but there was one last
surprise left for the fans by far the
biggest easter egg of the mandalorian
season 2 debut
came in the form of the most fearsome
bounty hunter to ever live
the legendary boba fett of course played
by timwarra morrison who also played
boba's clone father
django and two of the prequels from the
moment of the mandalorian's conception
audiences have clamored for fed to make
his big comeback on the show at some
capacity
after all he and the series main
character are incredibly similar
visually
and they're in the same profession so a
crossover felt like a given
the previous season didn't do much to
satiate this subset of fans
but thankfully for them season 2 is
going all in
now at long last jango fett's clone's
son is once again making his way to the
forefront of the star wars universe
and by the looks of things he's in no
mood to make friends
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian season 2 are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]